powerful message in the streets of
hollywood boulevard just outside the
dolby theater
as hollywood joins the sports world in
the fight against racial injustice
and one of the voices front and center
fast and furious star tyrese gibson
when you look at the nba basketball
players and what they're doing so proud
yeah there is no nba without nba players
it doesn't matter what they're paying
you you have a voice you are allowed
to say and speak and make your
statements nba playoffs resume tomorrow
but from new york to hollywood the
protests continue
all the marlins and mets have come out
of their dugouts
last night the mets and marlins took the
field observed a
second moment of silence and then walked
off the only thing left on the field
a black lives matter shirt also the rock
has postponed the launch of his new
training shoe
out of respect for jacob blake and his
family dwayne wade
showed solidarity dying his hair blonde
to show a black fist
symbolizing the social justice movement
for his part
fast and furious star tyrese gibson
today premiered a powerful new music
video
tyree said watching the death of george
floyd inspired him to create the song
legendary
and this video 8 46 a reference to how
long george floyd was pinned to the
ground
by an officer's knee i spoke with tyrese
at george floyd's memorial back in june
this all hurts man this is a very very
painful thing
our struggle has been we want to do
something but are we going to get
attacked
the video uses real protest video and
reenactment
and it features his daughters what did
that mean to you
so now you want to make me cry in the
middle of the interview
i got it what it means to me is
kevin my life and my kids life matter
too and guess what george floyd
brianna taylor trayvon martin eric
garner
ahmad and every other daughter and son
don't make me cry kevin
i also was very very moved by the ending
jesus the video's final moments show an
alternative ending to the violent
narrative
we've seen too many times
in tyrese promises to bring his activism
to another audience
fans of fast and furious the premiere of
f9 was pushed back to april of next year
when we do promotions and marketing
around fast nine
you're going to experience a very
different tyrese
you're going to be talking to tyrese aka
roman pierce right now
right it's all about legendary 846
and the traumas and the racial tension
and racial divide